Kevin Millar joins us Kevin would you
rather play in 95-degree temperatures as
a hitter or 65 degree temperature 65 and
even you can go tick lower reason why
you're going oh really yes that's weird
Kevin well Dan I feel in colder weather
starting pitchers can't grip that
breaking ball as well hmm
and let's say a pine tar so I'm going
colder weather more fast balls
I can leak that front hip like I was as
a hitter and groundout to shortstop
better wait wait what's leak the front
hip mean good question
so as stands back right arm up high I
leak that front foot I step in the
bucket they solid Danny yeah which means
that you pull off the baseball and you
stink on breaking balls now it was my
career all right you got a hundred
degrees 95 degrees tonight the ball is
gonna be jumping when it's hotter now
what do you expect out of these starting
pitchers trying to throw in that heat
what's funny because you got Keiko
obviously who's got to work almost you
know off the plates so if you think of
like a Tom Glavine you know doesn't have
the overpowering stuff guys stayed down
on the zone you know but that he's got
the nibble off the plate depend on who's
behind the plate doesn't give up a lot
of home runs Kershaw generally doesn't
give a blood of home runs because of the
devastating out pitches that he has but
the start before his last start his
seven starts before that he gave up a
home on every start mm-hmm so he's given
up the long ball this year I don't think
it's a factor I don't think the factor
for these two guys because generally
these two guys don't give up home runs
but it'll be interesting because Dodger
Stadium is not a hitter spark but it has
been terian in hotter weather and that's
what you know that's what might happen
late late in the bullpen now who do you
like I like the Astros you're gonna go
Wow my whole family grew up out here
I grew up out here my dad's out here
he's excited everybody's excited mom and
I got her daughter's because she grew up
without a fast
you know what I am a Dodger fan I grew
up a Dodger fan but I've lived in Texas
25 years
hurricane Harvey Danny I I would love to
see the Astros through this what didn't
you pick these two teams to start the
year I did I did before the season
started before everything happened
before everything Dodgers Astros World
Series Astros win it now is your n
rotator torn or from patting yourself on
the back or just because the Dodgers MVP
will be who if they win not say Justin
Turner right now really this guy's
turned into the top 5 to 10 in the
league before let me ask you a question
before the Chicago Dodgers series do
have Justin Turner if they're drafting a
league top 5 to 10 players in the
baseball no League no no after the Cubs
Dodgers series I don't know if he's top
10 but I just wouldn't want to pitch to
him in a situation where the games on
the line I just I I think he hits
anything you throw him and especially if
you're throwing a fastball he's gonna
murder you I don't know if there's a is
there a right handed well Altuve is
there but I'm as far as fastball hitter
Altuve is probably the best in baseball
but Justin Turner you can't fool him man
I mean he just why don't we why don't
why doesn't he get enough credit as an
offensive player defensive player great
third base yeah yeah our hits for
average is it the red beard because
we're not used to the red beards I think
that's what it is
like we're beer distill I don't like
guys with beards and I think that that's
why I don't thank you I'm not gonna give
Justin Turner's as much credit as they
should I don't like Keuchel either he's
got a beard and Kershaw has got to be
careful he doesn't let that grow a
little bit longer okay
yes hey you've never grown favorite same
girl face order I can I've ever seen you
I have you seen me in a Sandler movie
when I have a mustache I mean that's
real and then it's that's that's when
you really like you're all in on the
part see yourself in the back again as
Uncle Dan Levinson month with an okay
Kevin the MVP for the Astros will be if
they win
Brian McCann oh boy
yep I want I want I want I want lefty
hitter I want lefty hitter a lot of
left-handed starters I think I think
most underrated astro during this
postseason caught 10 out of 11 games
love his calm presence no huge last two
games was where I think was he hit by
Larry 3 / 6 a couple of elbows with
rabies mm big knocks so there's my
underrated sleeper veteran he clicks
maybe one of the bullpen guys are the
Dodgers all right I'm gonna take queeg
if the Dodgers win and Korea if the
Astros win you're really going to limb
man wait okay I'll go Bregman will go
third baseman's deal Turner and Bregman
how's that is the MVP yeah you're fine
with that
look I'm good with that Danny Lee Smeal
imagine with me that play at home plate
to Brian McCann was the key to the game
if that ball doesn't stay in the camp
you know glove you feel the Yankees win
that game now could bird have slid with
the other did he slide with the wrong
leg no no no no that's too corporate
television talk we're not we're not even
a Smith right now we're not gonna wait
wait wait wait but but does a
left-hander slide differently than a
right-handed hitter you know what that's
a great yeah okay I mean we all slide
differently I just blew your mind I
don't know you made me think a little
bit I want to la see inter-college I'm
looking at the
right now in Los Angeles I'm trying to
find perm on Melrose
where I was in the hood I'm looking at
him like this has changed Vermont
Vermont Melrose was my junior in college
on but it sounds beautiful now okay
would you look at that and maybe bring
it up to rows unintentional talk later
today do left-handers and right-handers
slide the same into the base do you
leave it have you ever watched an
episode of intentional talker yes are
you lying
not a full episode but I've watched I
mean like a segment I can't get through
that I mean it's like it's like I can't
get through a baseball game I mean come
on will you grow your goatee out for me
this year no I won't in the winter no I
will not no I'm so corporate no no
corporate I know but we're cold core
we're gonna cowboy up during the
commercial break here we're gonna do
shots
did you guys drink whiskey wouldn't you
guys drink with the red sauce the truth
of matter it was Jack Daniels with the
Yankees and Crown Royal with the
Cardinals so we slept the carlyle face
yep you want to just call it overall is
whiskey we'll call some bollocks toast
I'm staying with that Peter Gammons came
to that advice have fun today
alright buddy I appreciate you tell the
boys hi I want to see you to go to you
at some point
thank you Kevin Kevin always sitting
dead red Kevin Millar for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]